adam sasik here on behalf of
valuetainment we've all heard that
typically the most important factor
when voting is the economy aka it's the
economy stupid
so we're here in downtown dallas deep
ellum texas
to find out what people have to say
about the economy and their
own personal finances let's talk money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
all we talk is money okay let's talk
about the economy
how do you feel the economy economy's
going now mom well
it's not going great with so many people
out of work
the economy is rolling look at the
building that's going on around here
look at all the
all the hotels and the apartment
buildings and business centers that are
being built right here in dallas i'm
amazed at how much work is going on
it's the same way in chicago whoever
wants to say the economy is bad
is rolling right now i mean me
personally i don't think the economy is
going in a great direction it could
always
have improvements i just think everybody
needs to get paid more i think it's
going in the right direction i don't
think it's necessarily because of the
president i don't think economics is
completely controlled by politics oh the
wrong direction
because it's totally based on the stock
market i don't have stocks i believe
it's going in the right direction okay
the the stuff that he's done everybody's
401ks are
doing good and everything like that the
[ __ ] with china
like borrowing them from putting tariffs
on them and stuff
like he knows what he's doing i think
we're going in the right direction and
cove
kind of knocked it off balance
completely
it'll it'll recover it always does oh my
god inflation is going to be crazy
i think that uh you know i feel bad for
the small business owners and i think
that's going to be
it's going to take a while for that to
recover
really depends right now it's just you
can't really tell with everything that's
going on you know oh it's definitely
going the wrong direction especially
with covet i mean if we have to lock
down again because of his policies and
his
ignorance on the issue then the economy
is going to be way worse than we've ever
seen it
i think it's going in the wrong
direction because i've been watching his
business
closely and it's been like it's been a
really tough time for
all of the people all of my friends and
everybody that i know around uh it is
pretty decent in february i would say
but you know due to the spend i make
that's that's obvious right and because
of the pandemic it's going
pretty bad the wrong direction any
particular reason why
yes he opened the account the uh nation
without a clear plan
and so we're closing down again and
that's bad for gross domestic product
okay
i think it's going in the right
direction okay why do you think that
because i've seen an increase in sales
and in the e-commerce area
and other areas not necessarily in
merchant shops right now but
other places are growing i think going
forward the economy is
going to strengthen no matter who's
president you got a stimulus check
i did what did you do when you got that
stimulus check
i blew it
on it what did you blow it on what did
you blow it on oh i can't say that
you can't say it okay did you get a
stimulus checker
i did not i made i made too much way too
much one thing i will say is
god bless [ __ ] america where'd she go
which oh my god
sam get that sam get that hey
you guys are the most entertaining
interview of the day by far
by far no don't touch the pin now baby
that's american that's america now hey
hey personally i don't need a stimul i
don't need a
stimulus check but i'd like to see small
business get
get something what do you guys do for
work um i'm a restaurant manager
restaurant manager i'm a supervisor cook
supervisor and cook i'm a teacher i'm
retired i'm a grad student right now
i'm an industrial engineer played tennis
i'm a tennis coach too i'm a flight
attendant for a major airline i work at
home depot my
main job is i run a couple restaurants
but i'm also working on launching my own
brand at the moment
i'm a website designer i'm a truck
driver i work for a real estate
developer
real estate and i'm a lawyer during
covet
have your finances gone up down left
right have you taken on more debt have
you saved have you invested
what's your personal financial situation
it is all kinds of diagonal
like it is all over the place it is all
over the place my personal finances have
been going up because
i moved home so i don't pay rent my
finances have stayed the same
personal finances have gone up
but i've also started spending a ton of
money so there's that stayed the same
teacher's salary is higher here in
dallas isd
okay and um cost of living is cheaper
so compared to fort lauderdale it's
foreign it's it's a major difference
okay honestly not really no so status
quo
you haven't gotten better or worse yeah
the same basically yeah
i think more financially i've just been
more
into investing and just more like
securing
funds but i mean as far like i lost my
job
so i'll be going back to school just
kind of like ride this thing out
where are you investing how are you
investing give me a little insight gold
and silver
gold and silver she's a commodities lady
jen she's got food she's got bullets
she's got gold and silver gold and
silver you're like you're like the
the old west going on over here it went
bad you know like
yeah i mean you've gotten worse yeah how
about you same
same more or less more or less the same
i guess
okay yeah more that's the same i mean
for me like i
do my own like scheduling and stuff
though so it's up to me however much i
want to work
so so you're good financially yeah how
about you
mine's the same as a surgeon
i couldn't operate for four years at
four months so
i got hit pretty hard i couldn't see
patients
never in the million years that i think
that would happen
[Music]
and then i started my own practice
in march which is probably the worst
time in the world to do that so
yeah i got hit pretty hard you started
your own practice right when covet
started
yeah i didn't say timing is everything
john john got [ __ ]
i got [ __ ] yeah okay mine have been
affected greatly i was off work for
approximately four months
which was my decision i work i'm a
flight attendant for a major airline
okay and with the danger of kovid in the
beginning i chose to take a leave of
absence
down it's gone down right right so if
you guys
save more money taken on more debt have
you invested where you at
you know financially specifically i
would say i
saved more money but that was more an
effect of just not being able to go
out for many months probably spent more
spent more i feel like i saved a little
more why have you saved more and why
have you spent more cause i was bored so
i just was
buying stuff okay i couldn't go anywhere
and do anything so
all right so you were bored yeah in the
house and in the house board so you were
spending
exactly and you were saving because you
were bored of
being in the house being in the house
okay i always try to like invest because
i feel like investment is kind of like
paying a bill to yourself so it's like
my phone has been on the entire time so
i don't got a lot of money but i try to
invest like
50 100 so it's like has it gotten better
or worse i feel like it's been insane
for me
i save a great deal more than i did
before you save more so you're all about
saving that money
right now yes okay spend that money
save that money you save that money okay
save that money
respect save that money as you can see i
interviewed all sorts of people with
different careers
and different jobs and different
professions now half the people think
the economy is going in the
right direction which is encouraging to
see but the other half still think the
economy is going
in the wrong direction due to coping
what we also discovered is that some
people were actually able to save
more money during the pandemic which i
was happy to hear but others
had lost their jobs were struggling to
pay their bills and some were just
straight up spending money because they
were bored
either way what's important is that you
make sure you have a game plan
for your money in place and if you're
not sure where to start check out this
video
right here if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics
please do so below and as always save
that money all we talk is money all we
talk is